if we're all trying to figure out the
next generation in a way I mean it's an
interesting sort of thing we teach these
students we we are around these students
we observe them and hit a place like
Columbia or a pen you have these
wonderful gifted young people and we
know they're going to be the people who
will be significant leaders in the in
the future and it's important to know
something about them and and we can ask
them but you know they don't always tell
us what's really going on in their minds
how if it is true that the ways in which
people respond or sort of the sort of
the great questions of the time or what
they perceive to be the great questions
of the time and I think for Judy's in my
generation it would be it was going to
start with civil rights and then it
spread to the to the Vietnam War and I
mean this animated an enormous amount of
human action at among the younger
generation and spread over into the
environmental movement and this and that
how would you describe how would you
characterize that now that is what are
the great issues that are sort of
capturing people's motivations damn well
I definitely have here we go again I
definitely have a stencil of this issue
prior to being with NYC service working
at the mayor's office I was with an
organization city year and before that
achievement first I would say one of the
things i think this generation i do
think one important question is how are
we defining generations yeah i would say
a lot of what we are seeing the larger
service organizations the city years the
teach for America's they didn't come out
of this current generation and so we
actually are seeing the work I think a
past generation and we're seeing how the
current generation is responding to that
call but I think one thing that has
become clear to me is that we
do think the social many of us think the
social the civil rights issue of our
time is manifesting itself in the
achievement gap and I and I think we're
seeing that in different arenas so I
think the one that people point to often
is the achievement gap and how we're
seeing it in students academic
achievement based on their color and
their socioeconomic status but I would
also say that we are beginning to see a
gap in in just standard quality of life
issues health what type of insurance can
you actually have or you have no
insurance and so what type of medical
care do you have I think this need for
equality is something that has been the
same across the generations but I think
we're focusing largely now on education
and health okay that's very important
yep would add a third I think that
students today young people today are
deeply focused on the environment yeah
and if there is real action in
Washington I honestly believe it will
largely come from the kind of advocacy
that many people but younger people in
particular or showing and and and people
are really saying we're doing this for
our children and our grandchildren when
they talk about wanting to mitigate
against climate change think about
resilience and adaptation to the current
changes it's an equity issue and of
course it's a health issue and a poverty
issue certainly the face of it couldn't
have been more clear after Katrina so
what what environmental issues often do
is make more evident what the face of
poverty looks like in a particular place
and and really galvanizes both attention
and act
I am convinced that young people are are
captured by that notion they really do
understand that their planet and where
they will live in the next several years
is degrading very quickly as a result of
human behavior much more quickly than
anybody expected or paid attention to
yeah even 20 years and they are acting
yeah in very responsible ways and
forcing us to act more responsibly as
well I hope and so